so if somebody let's say they have a
couple of rental properties and they
want to do a flip they found a good deal
right what are some of those things that
you you have your system in place what
are the things that you can save money
on
whether it's fixtures whether it's
lighting whether it's tile and what are
the things that you're like don't cut
corners on these things this is
important these things you can find
deals on like
you know at the other day right it's not
really
his old numbers right
and you have to learn your numbers
because that's how you get ripped off
especially by contractors right right
the name says it all con tractors right
so I always buy my own material because
when you deal with a contractor they
usually uh put some more time raise the
price you know between 10 to 20 right
um you never want to give a contractor
too much money right that's a big
mistake that I learned at the beginning
you always want to break down that
payment at least anywhere between four
to six right payments because when you
give a contract too much money at a
certain point he gets lazy yeah because
he already has most of your money now he
has most of your money now he moves on
to the next job another guy's gonna give
him more money wait wait you all have
money that happens all the time yeah so
you gotta you know you gotta watch
things like that yeah buy a bulk
whenever I see a good sale I buy a bulk
just anything yeah anything yeah
what is it what is something that you've
noticed has gone up the most right now
like just as it obviously Woods I mean
we always hear about wood is it well
what what happened what down so what's
not bad steel is up like crazy yeah so
uh besides the flips right the regular
rentals we also develop properties from
scratch so right now I'm putting up a 50
unit building in Paterson New Jersey 80
unit and 100 unit right Jesus I just
finished my foundation and uh I just got
a quote for steel and it's almost up 50
cents more
then when I got a quote for it about six
months ago wow yeah so it's pretty big